ce genre de folie 2 oui et on se
retrouve pour l'épisode 2 2 je répète
hulst hollande alors dans le premier
épisode petit brief petite webcam petits
petits bobos ta gueule voilà à haut
risque ça que chercher on était donc
dans la chambre de la petite fille
on a donc de nouveau mais n'importe quoi
pardon mais c'est la chambre d'andy la
chambre jean louis borloo picanto
historique
bref on était en sachant qu'on a dû
trouver trois clés un petit peu cross de
chambre on est donc guidé par le gros
dinosaures que vous pouvez voir juste là
par exemple comment s'approche de lui il
ya un coffre dans lequel il ya un livre
qui nous dit où aller pour trouver quoi
donc là c'est la deuxième pièce donc je
pense donc ça va être une grande pièce
ça va être un salaire à ce jour là l'air
assez grand le salon pour le coup et a
eu lieu il ya un passage la botte pas ce
que j'allais me dire qu'en descendant
les marches on allait mourir c'est ce
que je me disais c'est bas des marches
sont un peu petites jambes pour nous
donc comme d'hab on est un check-in
wings c'est l'échelle 2 toy story 2
qu'on allait jouer pour ce qu on pas vu
le premier épisode je vous invite à
aller le regard des histoires de
comprendre un minimum
cette vidéo là un petit peu le principe
etc tu es en train de faire l'amour à un
point oui mais d'être au bout on serait
bien très bien
alors si tu sais ton truc c'est les
points écoute chacun son truc si tu
aimes le fist je l'attendais elle était
alors voilà on continue aussi recteur un
petit peu près un raccourci est un petit
peu 40 l'eso oui moi j'avais carotte
c'est ça si le moigne
il ya un point mais je crois qu'on va
arrêter de les prendre pas on va
continuer mais pour ça va on perd pas
trop tard battant c'est au moins trois
secondes parfois et si on en prend
vraiment un musique 30 quoi en sachant
qu'on les deux voilà une échelle je vais
pas perdre maintenant c'est vrai ou faux
attends je te regarde je vais pas mal
alors à temps aux [ __ ] lacets
accrobranche activités accrobranche ou
dans la vidéo je répète activités
accrobranche
alors ma côté mois 15 ans j'ai un mec
j'aime bien les lianes j'aime bien les
lions aussi thé wit voilà du coup à quoi
ça servait de venir ici je regarde ça
pas un truc battant moi je vais
batailler un point est un point à tanus
1.1 point il se vérifie s'il n'y avait
rien hop
faut aller là où je suis je crois non
mais j'arrive hop hop voilà j'y suis hop
hop
alors on entre alors lâchez pas trop on
est assez net hager c'est une étagère
très bien donc on est sur une étagère
est-ce qu'on peut pas monter là dessus
non je fais un petit peu le tour
d'accord là on a un cube avec une porte
renders distance phare ces thèmes avec
une porte
ouais on a une porte là alors on a une
boîte secrète d'accord donc j'ai eu un
truc pour faire secrète alors le livre
avec un bouton jolie alors dues aux
fraudes
on a trouvé une position secrète on a
juste à utiliser le bouton depuis le
coffre pour débloquer la porte donc
c'est à dire celui ci a poussé au groupe
de tonga où vivait sur le mur ah oui
voilà wendy stand pharma chat d'accord
non c'est un secret c'est un point de
vue traduit ça s'est fait avec un
logiciel dont quand même je crois que je
crois que oui en gros ils copient une
image et 360 le web parce que sinon ça
serait vraiment balèze c'est super qu'il
a fait à la main armée super beau c'est
bien fait donc voyez votre aventuriers
quoi écrire ouais c'est assez sympa
reprenez votre aventure alors
on peut passer par là autant dire que si
monsieur albert c'est cette touche pour
jamais tomber voilà comment ça se fait
que tu aies pas mort a rien dit parce qu
ils crient dans le foiral assez ça alors
il y en a qu ils adhèrent toi ouais avec
un hymne hongrie piggy hongrie puis
d'accord tu vois là tu me l'a juste
littéralement volé démarre assez pour
une fois c'est moi qui veut dire salut
balle je vois que tu a grimpé je ne sais
pas comment repartir à des points je les
ai mangés
l'étude doit prendre des points je pense
non ouais ben j'ai pris plein de points
donc je pensais que j'étais en mode en
mode gros gros agent secret qui m'avait
pas vu 40 le truc du cul tout ça vers la
baisse écrit dans le livre mais en fait
tu m'as absolument vu bon c'est cool
chacun son truc un arrêt c'est de
rejoindre le petit mouton de l'autre
côté de la sarine d'accord donc rien là
bas il ya un mouton
vous voyez premier objectif de la salle
rejoindre le petit mouton grillé ou un
petit mouton là en face là haut tout là
bas
weight of ont pu amener loin bon bah on
y va il est noir il est donc battant
fait le chèque pointe abbas attend sont
pas sots pas ce pas gévry gel
je n'ai pas souhaité j'ai cru qu'elles
ne sautent pas mon coeur j'ai fait
d'accord dont free j allais est tombé
amoureux de moi d'accord je suis mais je
suis tombé amoureux soit est juste tombé
voilà c'est exactement ça l'histoire bon
je suis là qu'est ce que c'est que ce
budget fois que mon gars octobre à temps
puisque via ton gros crâne dans ma vie
l'équipe du matin on avait vu des trucs
du genre alors j'avais jamais vu ça quoi
c'est un bon gars mais c'est un peu
malade c'est horrible c'est juste
horrible
moi j'veux pas nager pour un plomb je
trouve génial c'est les trucs qui
servent à rien d'annoncer j'vais prendre
tous les milieux mais ils sont mignons
mais petit point moi non je suis presque
48 times.la passage en rien passage
qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde
alors tout ça me plaît aux abattoirs
table ou que tu veux ça va marcher allez
on y va on y va y vas tu crois que
j'étais pas espèce de ouais je suis seul
conca pas compris pourquoi je ralentis
et open gt coupé dans ta phrase s'attend
à ce qu'elle joue elle-même tué qu'une
poule pour la peine je prends tout ce
qu'il ya dans les phases de poules ah
oui ah oui à quelques rires et puis
c'était vrai fin par contre je crois
qu'il y avait un nouvel objet scarlett
chip
j'ai eu un livre j'ai un livre alors
mais bon après des points
d'interrogation mais bon d'accord pêche
2,37 eur mode
merci buzz tu es mon héros je pensais
pas que quelqu'un pouvait m'aider mais
tu es venu prends ta récompense et lit
les prochaines instruction voilà dans la
cage des instructions mais mark bly pas
le checkpoint alors bien jouer buzz
il reste une seule chose à faire est ce
que tu vois le green coach devant la
télévision s'est gâté l'épisode attend
on va aller de l'autre côté comme ça
voilà au nord pour mon dieu qu'est ce
que tu as à tes pieds je veux citer peu
en l'air je me rate et pied à mon avis
il faut juste descendre alors devant la
télé la télé elle est là le green coach
abbas et le dinosaure là bas c'est le
site
or gars sait trop s'il ya une tasse
renversé il ya de l'eau il ya une tasse
renault va ça va nous permettre de
monter sur le halal halal à jade durable
et j'adore c'est tellement stupide et tu
veux mon poing dans la face
non non non tu veux au hall est mignon
tu veux le mien c'est pas meilleure du
tout ça cette visite
excellent mais il ya des je suis april
exit j'ai pris cher j'ai pris très cher
et bien pendant que tu pourras existe
vous allez voir notre chemin optionnel a
dans ce cas tu veux pas que je me tapais
sur toi bon à la limite gouailleuse et
si tu veux mais j'ai l'impression qu'à
pas grand char je vais prendre mon
procès mais choix radars non il y avait
juste un point que c'est comme d'hab
j'ai trouvé une trappe j'ai trouvé deux
trappes j'ai trouvé une mort que support
non mais regarde attends tu es toi parce
que moi du coup sûr je me suis retrouvé
chez non mais j'en peux plus y mourir je
suppute hein c'est juste le laac de
dunkerque ont fait pas si simple que ça
oui mine de rien il ya quand même des
petites voilà
adacore donc on vante est allé là bas
toi je suis pose devant la fenêtre
ouais j'avais dans la loi était le
gentil un point de vision sympa quoi ça
par contre c'est vraiment des c est pas
ça il ya une plante la banque est monté
sur la plante non sinon s'il ya une
trappe annonce pas celle ci dont il ya
un pont au dessus du toit juste regarde
[ __ ] mais j'en ai marre mais j'ai pas
l'habitude des frères en fait cette
capture sur shift quand même fait est là
c'est qu'on avait pas eu d'accord bien
jouer alors je crois que quand tu vas en
bas on ya une trappe
là dans ce truc là bon moi je vais
mourir comme d'hab
double trap et tu peux y aller un belge
et vas-y parce que moi sinon je vais
mourir je me tapais sur toi je pensais
mourir bêtement ya pas de sociétés gen
et plaît allez fais c'est de mourir
donc on va des points comme dame âgée
29.5 929 ouais bah tiens ben on est on
est en bas banic ait tant de difficultés
sur cette carte
oh là là incroyable qu'elle combat
épique auquel j'ai assisté dans laquelle
même si dans la came d'accord bon alors
faut remonter par la tasse il ya un truc
la hyène popo c'est quoi
j'ai eu alors là je ne sais pas il
craque insights un sac d'engrais
d'accord autant dire que le temps de
monter on attendait ce faire un café ça
bah c'est une tasse de café toute façon
non c'est de l'eau en passant lancé
cette bombe qui prend une tasse d'eau
sur cette planète
1 je vous le demande cherub sur facebook
tu me fais une tasse d'eau
merci le truc improbable
allez on est inodore hommage aux arts
alors living room l'âge et légumes on a
un espèce de deux coffres avec un oeil à
50 spéciale où tout ce qui est plus rock
dedans tu peut le retrouver s'il
retrouve le même score d'autre part
d'accor oui c'est super complexe
bon ben j'ai rien à mettre dedans que ça
tombe bien moi je mets plein de trucs
dedans moi bon bah allez je te vois tu
veux éviter d'avaler bon
alors le dinosaure living room j'te
l'dis alors et buzz dans la chambre
d'andy that was only award c'était juste
un warm je sais pas c'est quoi warm up
alors là je donc maintenant c'est le
temps du challenge dans la living room
tu as trois quatre majeurs et une quête
annexe h
la première quête est ce qu ils gobac
soft-r jeta promettre qu est donc c'est
leur tournée dans les escaliers qui
montent
ouais ouais rouet et de grimper on the
shell veut will 6 avant la greffe sont
d'accord johan found lost le petit
cochon est là elle a des points pour toi
makes you must risque uship wittstock
comme celle menée r2 windows
by cc pour la fée go go go there is no
time for winning books bah alors attend
les instructions devaient être dans les
autres livres
merci est ce que vous avez dit vous
devez parler d'un truc vert le c'était
lequel le carré magique c'est samedi que
c'était de sireix ouais ouais ouais bah
ouais
gator reward et louis next et
destructions dont je crois que les next
et lesquels s'étaient pas le secret
était peut-être l histoire avec le
bouton tu l'as vu toi en tout cas on va
aller aller en face de la télé voir un
truc vert ouais c'était ça et tu as vu
une télécommande 2 pouces donc par
contre pas tant parce que est ce que toi
tu vas pas le livre alors à quand j'ai
peut-être mis dans le coffre répliquer
mais enfin c'est ce que me disait
d'aller en face de la télé quoi papa tam
tout bon voilà on fait de la télé que
c'est quoi ben ouais on vient pour
gagner on va y aller euh non il est pas
tandis que tu as là bas non pas celui-là
se passionne non plus je ne sais pas bon
bah on a perdu
bah j'espère qu'on fasse de la télé on
trouvera et bien c'est parti on devait
aller aux mondiaux il attaque a rallié
au [ __ ] c 17 et u l'embuscade
d'araignée je plussoie there je sens
l'odeur ne marche pas c'est un mythe
cassez vous voilà c'est bon ils hd des
petites étoiles d'accord bon donc
comment me stopper dans mon délire
concrètement c'est ça ce serait à lui
seul cet ep en quoi te global dubaï mon
cerveau richer trop voilà donc c'est
comme ça et enfin et surtout qu'ils ne
savent pas pourquoi on paye d'ailleurs
quoi les scientifiques n'ont pas encore
trouvé pourquoi on bâille c'est sympa
moi comme ça monsieur rien d un passage
où ça moi je sais pourquoi on bâille
pourquoi mais fatigué non mais ça c'est
un petit truc qui dit que quand tu es
fatigué mais pourquoi pourquoi tu vas y
qu'on était fatigués parce que toi ça va
encore mais plus pour aérer ton cerveau
mais faire chaud
je sais plus dans de l'air froid dans
ton cerveau justement tu bail etc
eh bien nous ne savons pas donc c'est un
mystère
si tu vois ça mais voilà comment faire
si vous savez pourquoi de bayon allez-y
par contre j'en ai marre d'avoir des
gros plans sur ta tête
enfin je comprends pas c'est peut-être
que je n'investis joies et ses peluches
son cerveau en fait que ta tête c'est
plus long mais je vois un je venais en
jeu alors le plus grand père jeu non je
crois pas je crois qu'on tourne en rond
ça me stresse cette histoire j'ai
l'impression qu'on a qu'on a loupé que
je vais aller sur la télévision
bon attends je veille sur la télévision
la up
si ça va tu m'as pas trop que je suis
bon alors le souci c'est que maintenant
qu'on est sûr à la télé bonne chance
pour trouver le corps de nouvelles
télévisions d'ailleurs oui très bien
chez moi très bas le modèle ça me
soulage très câlin à regarde vient
passage bien à la télé oui romaine jean
voulu passer à la télé oui ou a été pas
mal celle là elle était pas mal j'ai
bien aimé d'accord donc je te laisse
faire il faut qu'il faut que je
réussisse un petit peu manga ouai quand
responsabilités
il faut que je m'entraîne je dois
m'entraîner tout simplement à temps je
saute jobs hier wen ice edge soit tu le
fais sur scène à à voile et coutumes il
ya quelqu'un il ya quelque chose là où
tu es où on n'arrive pas en fait pas
trop quoi
[ __ ] on a l'air bien cette toile a
pourtant c'est par là
ouais mais une fois attendait avant un
truc à faire ouais voilà à attend le sma
les voir avec terreur d'accord vas-y tu
es tu et les cloches
je tue et les clients mais le pauvre n'a
rien fait non non tu es et les clés rare
mais je pas le tuer moi je suis gentil
ouais par la journée avec cuvette qui
pètent un câble bon bon bon bah c'est
par là ouais bien sûr on est tous à
banon on se reparle aulas et c'est par
là c'est pareil c'est par est pas
tellement
heureusement que tu es là mon gars
j'aurais pas fait à un millième de la
même chose sans toi je l'attends c'est
complexe mais [ __ ] c'est quoi c'est
une xbox à xinhua que celle xbox de mule
truc vert et tout débarque 21 trigger
est aussi bon à il pèse 3 à côté bah oui
histoire que ça ait pas de jaloux voilà
pas de jaloux trois points c'est çà et
là que moi qui n'avais pas de point là
voilà donc c'est un petit peu à peu le
sexisme du console isme bon bref je ou
pouvons nous aller je me le demande
c'est le mystère à la une chaleur qui
descend à la main changement mbaye coup
je descends manuellement là on n'est pas
déjà lé là alors ya un point non non je
pense que limite les points ça va te
repérer quad c'est à ben merde et
djamila bon bah donc tu veux indiquer ma
théorie
absolument est ce que tu veux pas qu'on
retourne en se téléportant aux moutons
ouais sinon à temps fou il reste vingt
cinq ans sa mémoire par la mémoire par
la voilà sur le fauteuil peut-être qu'on
peut monter dans l'art d'être un truc
sur le fauteuil
ouais ben moi oui rien c'est joli
oreillettes au plafond ouah c'est la
nuit oui presque en moyenne grimper sur
le fil électrique ici le fil électrique
moi aussi je veux des barrages moitié
cork
bah oui je pense que du corps que lui le
corps d'accord e ht franchement ça ici
incorrect parce qu'on y arrive pas dire
tout cela a été très vite vous attention
très sociaux mais non je crois qu'ils
n'explosent pas en fait voulu on est un
peu un peu mou dans cette carte à la
barre garde compléter la quête du living
room mon premier souci c'est qu'elle est
où cette quête pas la question
[ __ ] on a trouvé là on a trouvé la
sortie en fait voilà un petit cochon
donc voilà l'épisode 3 pour bientôt
avec marvel on va faire ce que tu as dit
non on va les voir le voilà
autant se téléporter si on a loupé un
ouais on faire ça en ellipse tendresse
et de les retourner
ouais bah c'est partir du téléport toi
et moi je me tapais sur toi d'accord ok
donc quitté le porte
comment justement mode créative il faut
taper ce clash game mode un espace 1
avait laissé libre dans le coffre mais
n'ont même pas en plus même pas laissé
le temps commenté chris gay mode game
mode tout à fait d'accord j'y arrivais
est gay c'est quoi le game mode avec un
e mode ou en maths anglais
ouais avec un fou c'était la commande la
plus dure du monde à faire alors c'est
compliqué c'était très très dur j'ai
besoin d'être sur le tapis volant dans
la ligue
donc je relis vite fait le truc que j'ai
eu du coup clinton joe chef louise
bourgault in fine le speedy ship ppt for
your next few maastricht uship donc on
doit se courir le mouton qui est stocks
en chef dave the window
alors ça c'est le nom il est où le
ah c'est ça j'ai retrouvé de vue si the
green alors c'est quoi un coup de chance
on va dire ça
coach et canapés est ce que tu vois le
canapé vert devant la télévision
oui à j'entends des bruits dangereux à
l'intérieur
d'accord en fait il fallait rentrer dans
le canapé ok alors attends veille dans
le canapé et on retire le mode crash
arrive à sale odeur d'emmener ses tarifs
à la fois dit et de vieille garde
emmenée n'ont jamais d'accord on ne fait
pas de la chose étrange avec grâce à toi
je me sens moins seul je me sens encore
plus quand il est chauve souris [ __ ]
la vache tu viens tu t'étais sur moi oui
j'arrive très bien
alors son rang dans le cac est temps de
manger encore mal mais je m'en serais
d'accord donc ça c'est un guet-apens
inscripteurs fort alors attendant un
certain temps passé cinq ans la moitié
en vingt six membres effet ce night game
mode via rail mais zéro lieu du 1 au
quai ça marche parce que sinon c'est
invincible et ou syndicales c'est bon
donc c'est par là pour aller dans le
canapé attendait à mon avis ça parlera
moins d'eux on a raté un pied passe mal
donc on est dans la tasse d'eau alors
dont le flux est illimité je suis en
train de boire la tasse avait hâte en
tête à l'heure je pensais qu'il fallait
aller dans la tasse et qui avait
peut-être un truc dans un peu tête moi
je vais s'est lancée par notre passage
sur lequel je regarde moi dans la tasse
il ya rien donc aux à la barbare comme
des termites
non on va trouver le petit truc quand
même d'avoir un petit truc à faire dalé
des coachs tonnes attendez je vais
remettre le jour en appuyant sur le pif
du passé puisque youtube la lumière fut
et la lumière fut
peut-être qu'il faut y accéder par en
bas rhin tout compte fait j'ai cassé des
blocs
peut-être que oui c'est possible aussi
re y pensant je suis creusé la barbare
on va se permettre
allez un petit écart de conduite ah
ouais ah oui ah ouais
qu'est ce qu'il ya là encore me faire
défoncer la phase i avec toi
tiens cet accord c'est du canapé ben
voilà c'est là où fallait encore jeune
parigot portail jeunesse qu'elles
viennent en plus qui a déjà régné sous
son canapé
s'il vous plaît dans son canapé oui
c'est encore pire
[ __ ] mais là j'ai cassé vous coûte 120
g sûr il ya un repreneur en fait un truc
il est exposé obligé a pris la pire j'ai
pris les piles on voit ce qu'il est à
l'honneur derrière suivent a indiqué
d'entrée à mourir j'ai plus des pays
donc boom dans l'année faudrait aller de
l'autre côté tout a commencé il ya des
chaises et meneur au milieu vient de
mourir
non heitz
j'ai trouvé le chemin aux
questionnements non je suis tombé au
dessus bord je spawn dans mon canton
quoi dans mon attente j'entends me faire
crier il s'énerve quand un truc à lui
arrive souvent
oui j'ai pas contrôler ses nerfs les
énormes 9 heures à tenter paix
officielle je suis là mais tu es comme
entre les barreaux cours tour bah oui et
je cours je te suis l'un présente comme
une petite souris c'est dans un état
c'est assez violent je sais pas des
groupes attention piège
mais en plus free gel mahomet s'est
marié il me laisse crever comme un vieux
port tout ça autant dire que l'on parle
ici mais qu'il n'y a pas de sortie en
bus le pacifique ça m'a bien fait
toujours sentir
attention quant à lui quand même oui
bail je vais mourir ça dommage y'a pas
de sortie c'est un truc un petit mais
non mais non mais non mais non à toi que
aaa
tajan du défense explorer ça me balade
alors on les retourne ici mais j'ai mort
y avait quoi dans le coffre il y avait
eu des indications il faudrait qu'on bat
mais si je vais prendre à leur nom à
bagnères prise mais non c'est sa copine
mais je te dis que l'idée crise
je vais trouver des indications là
encore ouais olala moment il ya un moins
bon on s'en firent faut s'en fuir
or on est en dessous c'est me sébastien
savoie c'est bon alors il y avait crise
bonus donne alors good job bon travail
vous êtes maintenant le préposé astral
de l'espace voici ta récompense
maintenant tu peux aller à la cuisine
pour la quête suivante d'accord et tu
sais quoi en fait le labyrinthe c'était
une zone connue sur les points d'accord
ok mais bon
et ça c'est fini on a fini la quête du
salon alors justin n'a pas été simple
c'est ça oui c'était c'était plutôt ardu
là dans ce deuxième épisode le seul moi
c'était seulement l'once allemands l'ont
salles noires étriquées du salon était
salement nous voilà donc
bon c'était un beau jeu de mots qu'on
passe temps mais dr maintenant tu casse
tout donc en fait un petit raconte
hockey vaugeois le genre de personne
qu'on aime ça alors complète on voit là
bas on l'a fait avec sa cuisine ensuite
derrière bon on va te laisser sur un
point de vue la cuisine et voilà et je
vous dis à bientôt les gens pour le
troisième épisode ça se passera sur la
chaîne de free gel les gunners ont donc
passé moi sachez dans la description
abonnez vous pour être tenu au courant
des deux prochains épisodes qui
sortiront sur sa chaîne et moi je vous
dis à bientôt
pis friggit l'infini et l'au delà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]